[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans six ans
par les sports votre talk sur le sport
local c'est le printemps il fait beau
les températures commencent à remonter
tout doucement et nos chroniqueurs
sortent de leur tanière pour faire du
sport pour briller cet été sur la plage
ils sont quatre autour de cette table
présentation en musique on commence à ma
droite de son corps il le travail tout
au long de l'année sur son vélo c'est un
pistard qualité champion d'europe et qui
sera peut-être un jour champion du monde
le capitaine yann dujarrier pistard au
club de vélizy 78 est avec nous michael
quand allez-vous yann super super forme
donc vous travaillez votre corps tout
l'année c'est pas 15 jours avant
d'arriver sur la place qu'il faut se
réveiller en se disant oh là là j'ai
quelques kilos en trop j'ai quelques
bourrelets là l'équilibré alimentaire se
fait sur la semaine et l' équilibre
physique se fait sur toute une année
bien sûr vous revenez quand même d'une
séance de musculation juste avant
l'émission je suis à préciser sa pensée
de l'autre côté un musique qu'il adore
monté sur son cheval torse nu à travers
la campagne yvelinoise dès l'arrivée du
printemps
cheveux au vent on le surnomme dans
cette émission le taureau yves binois
ladies and gentleman
seniors i signori taha ou le côté
d'autres et cavalier international est
avec nous
quand allez vous prêt à vous et vous
michael moi super ça va très bien et
bien ça y est je suis torse nu les
cheveux au vent doit abaisser une
légende ou pas non c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est vrai je me rhabille
juste pour venir chez vous mais sinon je
suis à saillé donc pour les filles on
peut le dire qu'au t2 de plaisir ouais
c'est ça après tout les haciendas du
coin on passe de l'autre côté musique il
travaille son bronzage sur les terrains
de rugby où les parcours de golf dès
l'arrivée des beaux jours c'est pour
cela qu'il paraît toujours en très
grande forme comme aujourd'hui notre
russell crowe à nous pierre chevalier du
rugby-club de versailles est avec nous
salut michael salut à tous quant à elle
évoqué hier en pleine forme en pleine
forme au pluriel on va dire parce que
nous chez les rugbymans on prépare
et plutôt au resto et au bar deux temps
en temps en prépa physique voilà en
forme bonsai au top bronzage au top
toujours la banale celle avantages des
activités en plein air
on termine de l'autre côté musique c'est
une petite nouvelle dans cette émission
c'est une enfant des yvelines mais son
coeur et en afrique avec l'association
sos gazelle elle est également coach
mental est alors gagner chaque année le
célébrissime tiebreak qui réunit de
nombreuses personnalités véronique
chaplin est avec nous pour cette grande
première
quand allez-vous véronique pour cette
première en super forme ravi d'être
entouré de charmant jeune homme ravi
d'être dans les yvelines et les gérants
du sénégal donc la patate et bien le
sport au quotidien
alors vous vous faites du coup chaque
année le tiebreak est ce que c'est un
petit break c'est un rassemblement
sportif de haut niveau d'anciens
sportifs qui encadre des jeunes et
l'objectif est double on a une
compétition amicale de golf mais avec
ses champions il ya toujours le côté
compétition qui revient et avec un titre
de champion des champions annuel qui est
détenu par laurent blanc et à côté ça en
fait des olympiades où on a vidé des
écoles des yvelines et ils sont encadrés
par les champions avec différents
ateliers box rugby foot cette année le
basket avec des vrais conseils tant sur
le plan du sport mais également
l'alimentation le mental bien vivre
ensemble etc
et à l'issue tout ça il ya une grande
fête et des enchères caritative de
maillots et d'objets et 100 % des dons
sont pour l'association
voilà pierre cheval est un grand amateur
injustement d'enchères intérêts courant
et pourra déjà participé à un petit
break c'est vraiment un et à l'achat des
maillots mais également et elle
oui l'organisation des enchères qu'on
allait faire l'open de france à l'époque
et c'est vraiment un super événement
extrêmement convivial caritatif en plus
ce qui ne gâche rien donc c'est un bel
événement
ce soit au golf ont parfois au tennis
alors nous allons maintenant passer aux
probables de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler d'apnée avec un record
celui d'andy cabreira avila il a respiré
moins de cinq minutes en six heures pour
la bonne cause nous font également un
coup de projecteur sur le partenariat
entre le département des yvelines et le
tour de france la grande boucle passera
par le 78 jusqu'en 2023
mais avant de développer ces thèmes on
va parler rugby dans ce taudis
[Musique]
recommence ce tour d'horizon de
l'actualité sportive dans les
départements par une note très positive
le rugby-club de versailles et fêté ce
samedi à 23 mars la montée en fédérale 3
devant ses supporters dans une ambiance
électrique comme vous pouvez le voir sur
ces images et les joueurs l'auront fait
plaisir en l'emportant 37 à 12 face à
clichy leur 16e victoire en 16 matches
disputés on écoute le ressenti du
capitaine du rcv il était sur notre
plateau j'avais tout fait pour que ça
soit une grande fête en juin le samedi
soir et ça a permis à tous ces jeunes là
de venir nous voir jouer
légende a dû d'écoles de rugby les
parents les dirigeants des partenaires
donc c'est une super fête et et sa
sortie alors je pense tout un 10 2 jours
raul ils vont s'en souvenir toute leur
vie à votre avis j'imagine que oui c'est
une c'est une année forcément à qui va
rester dans les annales jeu
on discute et à l'heure en backstage
avec pierre qui me disait que ce n'était
pas arrivé depuis quinze ans une
quinzaine d'années voilà donc don qui
arrivent tous les 15 ans tous les cas
c'est se prête donc donc forcément ils
vont s'en souvenir ça très beau souvenir
là il y avait beaucoup de pression parce
qu'ils ont ils ont démarré on les
attendait très fort parce que ils ont
déjà ils ont commencé par une vie une
grosse grosse victoire dès le début et
la question était de savoir s'il allait
ne pas se reposer sur les lauriers et
poursuivre sur cette lancée ils l'ont
fait avec beaucoup de maturité donc
ouais ils vont s'en souvenir et se
j'espère que la relève s'inspirera de
7,2 cette belle épopée en tout cas les
grands acteurs de cette soirée étaient
les joueurs bien sûr mais également les
supporters on était avec eux dans les
tribunes
[Applaudissements]
leur montrer que c'est en fait le rugby
c'est vraiment une famille ici
versailles c'est vraiment une famille en
a inventé ça pour eux parce que il est
trop fier du parcours qu'ils ont fait et
c'est incroyable et juste lâchant
kiffante ans j'ai déjà plus de voix il
reste encore
tous trois quarts du match
mais ça vaut le coup de feu on est joint
aux supporters c'est pour les copains
qu'on fait ça nous on adore ça là on l'a
fait 3 l'an prochain ça va être le feu
avec dingue pas se déplacer dans tout le
quart nord-est de la france ça va être
terrible
avant on est là en l'ambiance partout va
chauffer la norme ou jimmy les dents pas
de calais tous à la hausse en l'a déjà
riez qu'est ce que vous en pensez de ces
supporters surexcités
moi j'adore et c'est vrai que j'y pense
toujours c'est vrai qu'on a quand même
un esprit très chauvin chez les français
et c'est très bien qu'un petit niveau
parce que voilà on est quand même
aujourd'hui en touche et versailles et
apparemment également et c'est ça reste
très local et voilà de pouvoir et de
vouloir défendre et d'encourager ses
athlètes
eh bien je pense que ça leur fait chaud
au coeur et il ya peut-être enfin il ya
certainement une partie du résultat qui
est aussi pour leur rendre pour leur
rendre hommage et pour leur donner du
plaisir au maximum
voilà ça on le dit souvent c'est ce sera
le 16e homme au rugby comme véronique
vous êtes d'accord avec yann fondamental
le lien avec le public et c'est quand on
est sur un terrain de sport pour un fait
de t'utilises compétition un marathon se
sentir soutenu ça fait voilà le mental
est important et quand derrière il ya un
public il ya c'est le lien humain
finalement qu'est là la machine repart
très important ça les pousse encore plus
se passer totalement
et qu'on compare dans tous les sports
c'est vrai les énergies on ressent cet
enthousiasme derrière derrière le le
champion où l'équipe est souvent
s'apaiser le petit chose qui fait la
différence au final pierre chevalier
c'est quoi l'histoire finalement de ce
groupe d'ultras qui a investi les
tribunes versailles va dire que c'est
laid c'est l'étincelle qui a allumé un
énorme feu c'est à dire que ce sont au
départ un groupe de copains de joueurs
qui se sont réunis pour pour monter ce
collectif ya un an et demi à peu près et
qui a été complétée au fur et à mesure
par les joueurs blessés par exemple pour
les joueurs qui ne sont plus dans le
cadre de leur travail ou leurs études
disponibles pour jouer régulièrement qui
ça grossit grossit et finalement ils ont
été ils ont été présents à chaque match
j'insiste à domicile et à l'extérieur
pour encourager les autres équipes et ça
a mené au fur et à mesure un nouveau
public très familial parce que ça reste
ça reste bon enfant ça reste ça reste
assez loin des de certains clichés
peut-être un petit peu plus négatifs on
peut trouver dans d'autres sports
je n'en vise aucun bien sûr et ça donc à
ramener des familles des enfants est là
l'apothéose c'était samedi dernier
effectivement pour fêter la montée pour
fêter le bouclage d'un projet de trois
ans qui nous emmenait d'honneur après la
descente en 2016 jusqu'à l'objectif de
remonter en fédérale 3 et surtout de
ceux de la base et ce projet sur de la
formation c'est-à-dire d'intégrer un
maximum de joueurs formés au club dans
les équipes seniors
cette année on a à peu près une petite
dizaine un petit peu moins une petite
dizaine de joueurs juniors montant de
l'année dernière qui jouer soit en
réserve soit en première et donc qui ont
participé activement à cette montée là
donc c'est tout ce projet qui prend de
ce qui prend du sens et là c'était
l'occasion en avançant le match dimanche
au samedi de pouvoir
de pouvoir remercier évidemment remercié
l'ensemble des l'ensemble des acteurs
des acteurs impliqués et surtout nos
jeunes l'école de rugby
le pôle jeunes de pouvoir leur les faire
participer à cette énorme événement et a
fêté la montée avec avec les seniors
avec un match phrasé a gagné haut la
main et un match est un match de
l'équipe première qui a été gagné un
petit peu plus difficilement mais qui
use qui nous maintient dans la scierie
de 16 sur cèze nature alors je rappelle
que pour l'instant versé n'a pas encore
remporté de titre ils ont seulement
réussi fin l'équipe a seulement réussi à
conquérir la montée disputeront ensuite
le championnat de france d'épée yoff de
fin de saison pour caricaturer en
quelque sorte pierre chevalier alors la
question sur ce thème
est ce que cette saison restera gravé
quoi qu'il arrive dans l'histoire du
club
oui ou non ou était alors véronique non
le rouge forcément et le vert pour le
finir alors on fait un petit duel entre
raul et yann dujarrier alors voilà c'est
vraiment de leçon d'avoir répondu à la
question
quelques quelqu'un reste et restera
gravé dans l'histoire est pour quoi
qu'il arrive a demandé qu'est ce qu'est
l'art et l'histoire du club - sagna
l'art il n'y a pas de titre bah moi
c'est pour moi c'est cette succession de
victoires c'est qu'ils me qui me qui me
surprend le plus donc oui puisque
puisque de savoir déjà la montée en rêve
3 et puis surtout le fait que d'avoir
survolé le championnat à ce point pour
moi à oui c'est pas bon si c'est si
c'est du jamais vu
pour moi ça reste déjà gravé un peu
compliqué sera gravé et elle sera
magnifique seulement si on finit avec un
titre aval que ce soit déjà en premier
mans premièrement le titre régional
et puis alors l'apothéose ce sera le
titre le titre national bien sûr mais
chaque chose en son temps
finissez en remportant déjà des 18
matchs voilà comme ça on reste sur une
bonne dynamique et une bonne
une bonne dynamique de victoires et puis
on enchaîne tranquillement avec la avec
les avec l'île de france est là en effet
à partir du moment où il défend ce sera
fait je pense que ce serait une trés
belle de pourquoi pour une très belle
très belle saison pourquoi est-ce que je
mets cette nuance et que qui restera
gravée dans les travées dans l'histoire
il pourquoi je mets cette nuance c'est
vrai que je pense que réussir à faire
les victoires consécutives plus un titre
derrière ce sera très difficile
il est possible de faire 14 13 victoires
et puis d'être champion et derrière les
diables est champion régional las il
enchaîne les deux ce sera vraiment
mémorable et leila righi resteront
gravés à vitam aeternam dans l'histoire
du club véronique qui vous a convaincu
il ya dujarrier ou raul raul raul
pourquoi grave et les des p tits elle
avait divers comme toi non non aggravée
parce que de sept victoires d'affilée on
va arriver à 18 mais surtout l'état
d'esprit qui règne ce qu'on voit les
images et du public et des joies sens et
ça va traverser les générations non
l'ours comme ce sont des émotions et
puis c'est le début d'une histoire et on
se souvient toujours du dernier par le
point de départ la première année les
basiques sont très importants donc oui
gradation puisqu'il faut bâtir un
nouveau binôme sur cette pierre
chevallier tv rhône il fallait que je
pense que tout le monde a raison moi je
moi je m'étais non pas par souci un
petit peu polémique et part et par
exigence
désormais on a on sait qu'on a un groupe
de qualité depuis le début de la saison
on ajoute aux as aussi le fait que ce
soit d'être dernières saisons pour
certains membres de l'équipe première
notamment
donc ils vont prendre leur retraite
des terrains à la fin de cette saison là
donc là une fois que l'objectif majeur
de la saison et est ainsi la montée en
fédérale 3 ce qui est déjà arrivé plus
d'une fois puis au club bien sûr c'est
vrai qu'il ya c'est il ya cette nuance
de peut-être potentiellement 18
victoires sur 18 matches qui serait
historique ait jamais vu mais vu le
potentiel du groupe
vu l'ambiance qui a ils ont de quoi se
ne sait écrire vraiment une belle page
qui restera gravée en allant chercher
d'abord le titre de championne de france
ça se jouera entre le 21 et le 28 avril
demi finales finale
et puis après le championnat de france
alors là c'est effectivement une autre
paire de manches parce qu'on va
rencontrer des équipes d'autres équipes
qui sont invaincus notamment dans le
championnat dans le championnat régional
bourgault verne bourgogne et puis dans
le dans la nouvelle aquitaine également
il ya deux équipes qui sont encore
invaincues donc là ça sera compliqué
évidemment pour graver il faut pour
graver dans le marbre
il faut il faut des titres il faut des
coupes et ce groupe on a réellement la
possibilité donc vous êtes exigeants
l'année devenus exigeants
on est devenus exigeants inouïe nous ont
donné énormément de bonheur on sait
qu'ils sont capables ils ont envie de le
faire donc oui on en 2010 vous le
souhaite en tout cas deux titres cette
fin de saison
je vous propose maintenant de retenir
votre respiration le franco cuba andy
cabreira ville a réalisé un nouveau
record à la piscine de saint cyr l'école
après avoir nagé en apnée dynamique
pendant six heures et 12 heures ces
dernières années cette fois ci il ne
respirait que 4 minutes et 12 secondes
en six heures en apnée statique ce
dimanche 24 mars
on écoute andy cabré à avia ya beaucoup
de choses qui bougent à vous avez vous
lu un conte et ses neuf top comme sur la
spree
c'est difficile mais moi je suis content
d'avoir fini j'ai pas aux gains de
capacité pulmonaire donc j'ai joué ma
force de volonté mais ces dégâts d'un
bon mental j'ai dépensé 1 comme au
président est arrivé à cuba
fodé venir à galindo fort de france
votre ressenti sur cette performance
véronique hallucinant et quand on sait
que la respiration l'oxygène c'est la
base du sportif de l'être humain déjà en
général ça vous impossible 4 est
vraiment respect respect respect c'est
même surprenant
pierre chevalier je vais même pas
compris le titre en le disant
je croyais qu'ils croiseront ils avaient
fait d'affilée en gros des longueurs par
exemple jusqu'à 4 minutes de respiration
mais l'incident faisait avant en fait là
il a fait de l'apnée statique qui est
spécialiste du secteur dynamique
à la base j'ai même du mal à me
présenter pour présenter les
possibilités énormes lors on a pu voir
sur les images il va se dire moins d'une
seconde
en fait à chaque chaque lever toutes les
8 minutes humide demain comme on peut le
voir voilà sur l'image
il va relever la tête dans un instant
pour respirer voilà il va investir parce
que dans ces cas là moi même dans le
petit bain benoît jarrier wifi est
adepte des grandes performances
bah oui je m'attends à encore parler de
ta vie' c'est vrai que j'aurais dû lui
passer un coup de fil pour éviter le
pire al-hilal bon voilà qui est un qui
est un très bon copain bien et et
j'aurais dû l'appeler pour avoir des
informations sur 7 sur cette performance
le temps me l'a pas bhl a pas permis
mais c'est vrai que
ouais non moi ça m'impressionne
j'avais pas compris non plus de la
manière dont il avait pu le faire mais
de toute façon
voilà
même dû se dire gérer il a respiré cinq
minutes sur six heures c'est quelque
chose qui est vraiment incroyable
une force de à une force de caractère
une force d'esprit un quelqu'un de
quelqu'un d'admirable voilà je pense
qu'ils mériteraient à être un peu plus
connus et reconnus parmi parmi tous les
sportifs parmi tous les sportifs tout
simplement
raul quel est votre avis sur cette
performance bah couper le souffle coupé
c'est cette dimension aussi du du du
sport que j'aime c'est savoir se battre
contre l'adversité et créer des exploits
mais aussi quand on arrive à un point où
où le sportif ou même l'équipe arrive à
repousser les limites de l'organisme
humain quoi et à battre des records là
c'est vraiment ce qui est ce qui
m'impressionne le plus fameux des
records de vitesse ou autre ça c'est
finalement ses besoins dans ce qui est
impressionnant c'est le mental dans ce
type de performance véronique on le voit
il est resté statique pendant six heures
sans sortir la piscine c'est le mental
finalement qui joue oui et dans vos
quêtes coach mental exemple à pendre
dans tous les sports amateurs ou
professionnels qu'est ce qui fait la
différence techniquement tactiquement
etc
il ya beaucoup de champions mais au
final les suprêmes c'est le mental est
là et là tu mets typiquement le goût de
la lorraine mais l'exode ou c'est un
petit alors je sais c'est donc fort et
bien vers une transition justement son
gland et tafer également pour la bonne
cause il s'est lancé ce défi pour
dénoncer la maltraitance des animaux
marins dans les parcs aquatiques
on les écoute tu me mène à la promenade
enfants qui doivent vivre en liberté et
nager 5 km par jour
et c'est nourrir des poissons vivants
alors être tous la vie à perpétuer
impressionné simplement pour la placer à
décembre
c'est pas juste non je pense qu'elle est
message est là la question sur ce thème
comprenez vous sa démarche
oui ou non de rester dans une cage pour
dénoncer la captivité des dauphins
notamment
oui suivant véronique on ne peut
qu'approuver ccc exemplaires
effectivement il mériterait qu'on parle
plus de lui c'est bien d'en parler
aujourd'hui
et voilà c'est c'est par ce type de
record qu'on peut sensibiliser les gens
à votre avis il y avait là
malheureusement j'ai vu un reportage est
pas très longtemps sur un très bel
aquarium qui a été fait qui a été créé
au japon avec des moyens colossaux par
un par un milliardaire japonais
en effet c'est vrai que pouvoir voir des
comment ça peut être des femmes et des
mammifères des poissons des meilleurs
marins des poissons de toutes sortes
comme ça en se promenant dans des allées
pour nous c'est formidable mais c'est
vrai que ben
on pense pas toujours cloud défunt par
la qualité de vie parce qu'ils ont plus
de qualité de vie mais à la vie de ces
deux de ces animaux même si c'est vrai
que des dauphins aime être au contact de
l'homme et pouvoir faire des shows
pouvoir faire des salsas les amuser et
ça en reste ça reste un plaisir pour eux
c'est vrai que là j'ai une copine qui
était parti en martinique qui a fait une
photo à parce que les dauphins sont
venus nager à côté du à côté du voilier
ne serait-ce que ce matin sur j'ai vu ça
sur facebook
c'est vrai que basses sont quand même
mieux certainement dans l'eure dans leur
milieu naturel je pense que nous aussi
on aimerait pouvoir on n'aimerait pas
justement avoir ce type de dents
cloisonnement quand on est puni quand on
a fait une faute en dans notre dans
notre civilisation d'envoi en prison je
ne pense pas que ces mammifères et fait
une erreur où il fait une faute pour se
retrouver en prison
derrière donc donc voilà c'est c'est le
contrebas lancement
comment comment lutter s'assurer que les
conditions sont sont corrects et sont
les meilleurs pour c'est pour ces
animaux et puis
mais voilà on a on a envie la curiosité
humaine fait qu'on a envie de les
découvrir dans leurs dents dans
n'importe quelles conditions
mais je pense qu elle le milieu naturel
c'est ce qu'il ya de mieux
c'est pas toujours faisable et c'est pas
accessible à tout le monde donc voilà on
assez coc au aquatique qui nous
permettent cela mais c'est vrai que
c'est pas c'est parce qu'il est idéal
comment comment lutter est ce que est ce
qu'il faut continuer à ce qu'il ne le
faut pas je vois là je peux pas on peut
pas ne peut pas le de contrebalancer on
peut pas prendre de décision mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya une vraie réflexion à
avoir sur la dessus je vois des balles
il y avait besoin de limiter ces cinq-là
chalcolithique précisé version alliés
précisément sur sa sur sa performance je
trouve qu'on parle pas assez de la
finalité des hackers ont
vous couvrir l'événement et vous êtes
peut-être les seuls à le faire et le
confrère de la presse locale également
et le mélange est ça le message qu'il
véhicule et sur lequel il se barre un
appareil quand finalement qu'en fin de
couverture et on sait on connaît la
finalité son objectif qu à la fin donc
même même sur sa performance on va
retenir la performance physique et la
performance mentale physiologique qu'ils
réalisent peut-être moins un petit peu
sur le message mais en tout cas l'a
enlevé le message à votre avis on
n'oublie pas mais il est payé pas
suffisamment mis en avant
après c'est celle là c'est bon
maintenant là on a rétabli l'équilibré
est ce que les autres le font pour dont
six heures d'efforts pour que yann
dujarrier on parle de nude atténue son
but ça fait quand même très légers
toujours deux minutes de fréthun oui
mais avoue frère raul qu'est ce que vous
en pensez du coût de ce message
d'utiliser son corps pour véhiculer un
message je pense que de toute façon il
faut faire quelque chose d'un petit peu
improbable où
ou inédits pour réussir à véhiculer un
message sur lequel on n'est pas sensible
donc je crois que c'était aussi
stratégiquement une bonne tactique
moi je parle c'est peut-être même aussi
un sacrifice qu'il a fait j'imagine que
cinq minutes en six heures ça a dû être
il a dû passer aussi par je pense
quelques moments de grande souffrance et
je crois qui s'est vraiment sacrifié
pour pour pour passer ce message là ben
oui oui je pense que oui je pense que je
pense qu'il faut continuer à faire la
démarche que vous faites en ce moment de
mettre le coup de projecteur là dessus
et de véhic et de le véhicule et surtout
ce message il peut évidemment qu'il est
pas encore assez passé puisque est une
société de consommation qui est qui
existantes et qui est encore sans limite
vis-à-vis d'eux david ces espèces là
mais je ne crois pas que ce soit là une
raison pour arrêter ce genre de ce genre
d'actions qui visent à améliorer la
situation
véronique est ce qu'il doit faire un
autre oui un autre record de ce type
pour encore sensibiliser le grand public
oui qui viennent et 1 2 3 ou un pupille
c'est toujours la même chose
effectivement on est dans une société de
consommation où les vrais passionnés
oublie la télé les images le marketing
etc
alors qu'il ya des gens qui n'utilisent
que ça lui ça mériterait que quelqu'un à
côté de lui qui lui qu'il l'aide pour
médiatiser à sur le plan national
international
donc c'est un débat mais oui il faut
qu'ils refassent puis on sera là pour le
pour l'aider à avoir oublié
retour sur terre maintenant va
maintenant passer notre page coup de
projecteur on va parler de course à pied
dans ce coup de projecteur le samedi 16
mars dernier l'éco trail de paris était
organisée entre l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines et la tour
eiffel un parcours de 80 km qui a
réalisé fabien parmentier pour la 12e
fois cette limite a terminé à la 4 108e
place avec une vitesse de 8 65
kilomètres/heure on les écoute il était
sur notre plateau s'est sorti un petit
peu la mode en ce moment en sortir de ma
zone de confort et puis effectivement
essayé de repousser tout le temps un
petit peu ces mythes alors bon je
rebrousse chemin
pardon je ne repousse plus mes limites
sur l'éco trail mais du coup ça me
permet de lancer un petit peu ma saison
et puis et puis effectivement de
m'inscrire sur des courses un petit peu
plus longue pour le reste de l'année
un autre est ni mon teint à réaliser
cette année son deuxième eco trail sont
longs à sidy diallo il a réalisé les 80
kilomètres après avoir passé tous les
jours de la semaine à courir au minimum
un marathon dans les caraïbes
il a terminé à une honorable 1580
deuxième place avec des micros
chaussures en écoute c'est une promenade
avec à chaussures minimalistes parce que
la forêt la nuit
en fait nous sommes des chasseurs à une
espèce de chez kia met en chasse est là
le jour et la nuit nous étions les
proies en cours de la nuit dans la forêt
c'est pas naturel pour nous les humains
donc là je les fais avec les chaussures
minimalistes la question sur ce thème
sont ils fous oui ou non non oui oui
alors un petit duel entre véronique et
gagne gériez véronique véronique ben moi
je suis marathonienne gingembre qui fait
la diagonale du fou les huîtres alex
extrême max et oui faut être fou sur
l'île de la réunion c'est ça oui il a
fait la dernière et faut être fou dans
le bon sens du terme sert pouvait
m'aider challenge complètement dingue
pour avoir couru sept marathons
ce gala qui fait six marathons à philly
tous les jours cette marque 7 marrade
sept jours plus l'eco-trail de 80 km le
huitième le huitième jour il ya comme ça
sur le huitième jour un marathon on a
beau dire l'organiser tête abîmée il dit
qu'il est cool c'est épuisant et et on
va chercher dans des ressources extrême
à partir du 30e
il le fait cette fois il ya en plus des
blessures etc
des micros blessure d hydratation etc et
c'est encore du mental faut être fou
mais foule a du mental dans les abîmes
oui on a du bon mentalement fou fou fou
dans le bon sens du terme
il ya déjà riez non pas fou parce que
vous avez dit sont ils des fous je ne
parlais pas de
rappelez moi sans nom si je ne parles
pas de ceci dit je parlais de revient
par bonté
j'ai parlé du même de tous de tous les
participants 80 km aujourd'hui pour des
coureurs à pied c'est quelque chose qui
est maîtrisée dans le dans le niveau du
trail là où pour moi justement on pas
parler tous et sur la diagonale et ça
elle porte bien son nom
là c'est vraiment un effort un effort de
fou mais 80 km voilà c'est quelque chose
qui se fait sur un sur un timing de 10
12 heures pour des coureurs pour des
coureurs moyens ou des bons coureurs
après le reste basse et des coureurs qui
vont qui vont simplement vouloir aller
au bout donc on n'est pas obligé de se
met dans un état dans un état de fatigue
finir avant tout faut finir avant tout
bien sûr et donc c'est la préparation
c'est l'entraînement qui fait qu'ils
sont capables de gérer ce type d'effort
alors deux possibilités soit c'est
l'entraînement oui et non fabien par
vente elysées dans l'ensemble des ados
qu'il lançait sa saison et qui ne
travaillait pas beaucoup pour préparer
les go cet événement pas là donc c'est
c'est là où je voulais venir cette crise
soit c'est une habitude pour eux de
faire ce type d'entraînement parce que
j'imagine que fabien à une période de la
saison et bien un effet ce type
d'entraînement
quasiment tous les week-ends ce type de
certification tous les week-ends et donc
pour lui c'est du banal ou alors eh bien
c'est le pic de la saison et donc ils se
sont préparés pour être au top de leur
forme sur ces 80 km donc pour moi quand
on s'aligne sur ce type de sur ce type
d'effort enfin mettre des forts des
preuves tout doit être maîtrisée on n'y
va pas on n'y va pas comme un 10 mille
que l'on pourrait faire sans
entraînement où on va mettre une heure
une heure dix une attelle mais si je ne
peux pas laisser dire je parle de signer
où les participants je parle bien de
tous les participants
6 10 pour moi il est dans un monde à
part sur sa planète on en a déjà parlé
et débattus ici c'est quelqu'un
d'extraordinaire voilà et je pense que
dans les questions veut ordinaire et qui
oui mais que tout le monde joue sept
jours et faire un écho très il lui
j'avais j'avais la même après j'avais la
même impression quand moi je j'ai
commencé à avoir des résultats
je disais c'est mon entraînement qui
fait que j'essaie résultat aujourd'hui
et maintenant je m'aperçois que en effet
c'est peut-être pas donné à tout le
monde parce que il faut pouvoir
encaisser les charges d'entraînement
faut pouvoir avoir le mental de de
déchirer aux entraînements de se
déchirer sur les compétitions de vouloir
dans l'adversité et de se remettre en
question tout le temps c'est pas donné à
tout le monde et donc voilà c'est pas
donné à tout le monde et pour moi aussi
dit en effet je pense que c'est le même
type d'athlète que que le que l'apnéiste
de tout à l'heure ils sont sur la même
sur la même sphère dans l'eure dans leur
domaine pierre chevallier
si on parlait sports comme le terme de
l'émission c'est que je trouve
fantastique en ce moment c'est que c'est
cette drogue et 7 cette explosion de là
je vais pas appeler la mode mais cette
explosion de la course à pied que ce
soit en gros sur les marathons sur les
semis
sur les petites courses des plus petites
cours de 10 km par exemple sur la grotte
pour ça ira moins en plus qui a fait nos
malades parce que c'est le sport qui
rendent chez vous s'il n'y a pas besoin
de grand chose c'est pas forcément très
chiant une bonne paire de running pour
après quand on se met à vouloir
s'équiper
ça va vite ça coûte vite cher mais je
trouve fantastique cette pratique une
quasiment universel du sport avec en
plus quelques quelques images comme ça
qu'ils sont qui permet d'emmener
quelques heures quelques personnes
handicapées sur les courses
donc ils sont fous sur le dépassement de
le dépassement de soi dans ma carrière
avec mon presque quintal j'ai fait un
marathon un finisher marathon je sais ce
que ça coûte de la préparation je sais
ce que ça coûte enterrement tel comme le
disait 0 sur le sur les ressources à
aller puiser là 80 km entre elles le
jour et nuit et à les monter la tour
eiffel à la fin et puis toutes ses
courses quand on prend la grogne le
marathon des sables
le lin diagonale des fous je pense
qu'ils sont fous dans la dans la dans
l'objectif d'aller se dépasser mais
qu'est ce que c'est bon quand on y
arrive
quelle que soit la quelle que soit la
performance j'ai fait j'ai fait un temps
ridicule mais j'étais allé au bout et ça
et ça ça c'est pour tous tous ces
sportifs
on pourrait appeler ces sportifs du
dimanche le dépassement de soi leur
caractérise une petite folie mais mais
elle est elle et elle est agréable à
pratiquer mais derrière questions sur ce
thème
finalement quand on regarde bien les
courses qui sont proposés actuellement
des 80 kilomètres des 100 kilomètres
parfois
est ce que le marathon finalement ne
vient pas obsolète
quand on voit par exemple un eco trail
comme celui là et qu'il y a de plus en
plus de coureurs qui viennent s'inscrire
sur ces courses est qu'ils disent à la
fin je suis venu pour m'entraîner
finalement règle non parce qu'il ya je
sais il n'y a aucun format de course
qu'il est obsolète le format de course
il a son intérêt et son côté sa grille
en fonction de la manière dont on la
cour
donc c'est pour moi un homme aucune
distance ce cas aucune course proposé ne
devient obsolète c'est de la manière
dont on a deux de se comporter au sein
de cet effort-là qui qui va le
différencier des autres ou dans
l'histoire
voilà mam est sur le point que soulever
pierre c'est vrai que moi aussi je ça
fait plusieurs déjà des missions que je
salue cette nouvelle mode ça fait 10 ans
et essayer même même grâce à en général
je suis plutôt à dénoncer les effets des
réseaux sociaux d'autres choses mais
c'est vrai que c'est devenu un effet de
mode et tout le monde se montre beaucoup
à faire du sport et c est le même les
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui on est
obligé de se sentira un peu obligé
d'aller à la salle de sport de courir
d'avoir des parties de la communauté
d'agglo tout ça moi moi pas forcément
dans tous les cas c'est en général c'est
plutôt néfastes ce qui se passe d'un
point de vue socio et de ce côté-là non
les gens font beaucoup plus de sports
vainqueur il ya dix ans et ça je le
salue à ses salariés et le crossfit
white qui sont qui sont deux activités
qui sont typiquement exactement est très
en vogue il y ait sur l'émulation des
réseaux de socialisation de salle de
boxe fréquentait qu'en france en ce
moment et même par rapport au format des
courses moi chaque fois que vous me
posez la question parce qu'il ya des
courses que qui sont réservées qu'aux
femmes ou dépenses qui sont réservées
qu'aux ces femmes aux robes longues et
n'importe quoi je le dénonce jamais je
me dis que de façon n'importe quelle
course à partir en amour elle est créée
et l'incitent à courir et bonne quoi
cette thématique et aurait justement par
les boks d'un autre fonds salueront tôt
[Musique]
de la boxe dans ce focus tony yoka
originaires de chanteloup les vignes
dans les yvelines champion olympique
sera de retour en juillet après une
suspension d'un an vainqueur de ses cinq
premiers combats chez les professionnels
chez les lourds
le boxeur de 26 ans veut maintenant se
tester au meilleur il envisage même de
combattre contre l'actuel champion
invaincu le britannique anthony je suis
à fin 2020 début 2021 si ses prochains
combats sont concluants on ne saura plus
dans les prochains mois la question sur
ce thème
est-ce que ce combat arrive peut-être
trop tôt il reste à peu près un an et
demi oui pour véronique notre auto non
non est-ce qu'il arrive surtout le nom
pour vous non un petit duel entre pierre
chevallier et raul
raul vous êtes seul contre tous oui
alors oui mais l'exercice est difficile
parce que je suis un grand supporter de
la boxe anglaise en france et qui plus
est dans les yvelines parce que je
fréquente une seule scène heavy noise et
et tony et yvelinois mais le problème de
tony hawk à ce qui fait partie d'une
génération où on n'a certainement jamais
connu une catégorie poids lourd à
l'échelle internationale aussi relevé
entre anthony josue wilder furie et même
en france avec carlos takam et
et du haut parce c'est c'est très
difficile pour pour tenir au cat de se
frayer un chemin
après je sais quelque chose que j'avais
déjà dit aussi précédemment
le problème des jo c'est que ça ça mais
certains boxeurs amateurs sur sur une
certaine scène on se met un coup de
projecteur sur eux alors que on est
quand même très très loin de la réalité
de la boxe professionnelle
c'est un vrai le titre olympique qui
laissa faut savoir sans titre amateur et
il ya qui pourrait évoluer qui peut
évoluer mais d'ailleurs tous les grands
champions est passée par là et ça reste
une bonne une bonne
un bon passage obligatoire et
préparatoires mais on voit très souvent
des boxeurs olympique briller et ensuite
ne jamais les voir
avoir un titre un titre international
la route est longue pour lui parce qu'en
plus il ya eu c'est pas le mieux classé
français en fin de compte tenir qu'à
c'est peut-être le plus connu mais il
est il et qui a deux boxeurs de
challenger devant lui et don dont un
carlos takam qui a perdu contre je suis
à et une revanche je fais promise donc
déjà et et puis qui en plus ces deux
sont des boxeurs
quand même d'une meilleure 30 points et
la différence d'âge entre entre joshua
et et tony yoka lé lé 3 en trois ans à
peine trois ans 29 ans pour cela et 26
ans pour tenir aucun c'est compliqué
c'est d'abord compliqué d'avoir un titre
et sa part moi je ne vois pas comment ça
pourrait se passer
et en plus d'avoir un combat parce que
je veux dire à monsieur comme je suis un
boxeur comme je suis assez quelqu'un qui
fait des choix aussi des choix
financiers stratégiques et lui il n'a
pas encore réunifiée sa ceinture il a
parlement expression et d'autres chats à
fouetter pour l'instant et d'ici à ce
que la porte soit ouverte pour tony hawk
à puis lacoste il a que cinq combats
professionnels
attention cette condamnation à l'ex
canari en soit fort qu'il faut voir les
déjà l'écart en les oui mais faut voir
les quarante les 40 premiers mondiaux de
victoires en 22 combats dont 21 par ko
ouais et wilder c40 voilà c'est quand
même klitschko klitschko qui qui qui qui
n'est pas qui n'a pas qui n'a pas encore
sa licence
donc bon et wilders s'est c'est ses
quarante 40 combats 3 38 victoires de 30
37 ko quelque chose comme ça donc contre
le gabon il vient encore fournir ce qui
reste un peu de place dans ce combat sur
certains types et le tony hawk accroître
leurs tenues de chaussures encore
peut-être encore plus amateur
normalien il y avait deux points qui me
de points qui marque là dedans le
premier c'est c'est le l'évolution de la
carrière de joka qui était parti très
fort et effectivement à ou le rappeler
sur sur un titre olympique qui ne vaut
peut-être sûrement pas dire qu'il veut
sûrement pas dire la même chose que
qu'une carrière professionnelle et le
deuxième point c'est sûr mais je dirais
une opération reconquête pour pour tony
hawk heures sur le premier point il
était suspendu un an je dors à la peine
pour ne pas s'être présenté à 3 contre
le continent a agi dopage et si on me
prend ce deuxième point ce deuxième plan
en premier c'est que c'est le il n'est
pas trop tôt justement pour se remontrer
et puis pour aller pour aller de l'aller
à nouveau de l'expérience il a eu il a
eu un nom d'un an de parenthèse aller se
frotter aux meilleurs kits qui takita
redescendre sévèrement du ring et à
tomber à tomber ko sur ce combat là s'il
arrive à le monter s'il arrive à
s'aligner ça sera jamais dû perdre il
faut qu'il faut qu'ils rattrapent du
temps perdu
on sait on sait de quelle manière il l'a
perdu sur cette année de suspension
là aussi ce sera à gommer à effacer donc
il n'est jamais trop tôt pour démarrer
après finalement il n'a raté que un ou
deux combats pour une année voilà mes
mais bon le plus tôt sera le mieux donc
c'est pour ça que je réponds je réponds
non c'est pas trop tôt et puis et puis
pour le premier point de reprendre un
petit peu le fil de sa carrière par être
passé de ce statut d'amateur à
professionnel avec avec une mise en
lumière qui a été effectivement
extrêmement rapide pour lui et sa
compagne
tout de suite après des titres
olympiques bon maintenant il était il
était dans très attendu au tournant il
n'y a pas eu d'appel eut le temps
d'éclore il a quand même un gros
potentiel au niveau amateur
maintenant allez alléger l'aller le
il faut il faut savoir ce qu'ils vont
donc il n'est pas trop tôt pour ce pour
aller se confronter aux meilleurs quitte
à tomber de haut le cas échéant mais ça
sera pour pour repartir encore plus haut
et se relevait bien de gérer qui vous a
convaincu pierre chevallier
je suis là et c'est difficile de
départager
raul est connaisseur et donc à très bien
très bien défendu moi j'ai le même avis
qu'eux
que pierre c'est à dire que vous allez
vite non pas vite parce que je suis
désolé on est en 2010 9 en début 2019
on nous parle d'un combat en 2020 voire
2021 ça veut dire si c'est fin tout va
bien si tout va bien donc ça veut dire
encore deux voire trois ans avant de
pouvoir monter sur le ring face au
champion du monde ça veut dire que entre
temps il a le temps de pouvoir taper
encore d'autres d'autres adversaires qui
vont lui et et moi je lui souhaite même
de prendre une de perdre un combat parce
que dans la dans la défaite
eh bien il va apprendre encore ce ne
sera pas une défaite c'est à dire qu'il
va y avoir de l'apprentissage et ça lui
servira pour la suite donc alors s'ils y
arrivent comme comme le choix avec que
des victoires et bien tant mieux parce
que demain c'est très sympa de gagner et
de gagner tous les dimanches
bien sûr donc de gagner tous les matches
et ça que dans la boxe m'a
malheureusement on convainc pas tous les
dimanches on combat deux trois fois par
an grand maximum
donc oui c'est très bien s'il peut le
faire mais il faut que ça se fasse par
étapes
il faut aller d'abord enfin gravir les
échelons et donc montrer qu'on est
capable et qu'on peut merrill mérité
l'honneur de combattre qu'on chante
contre au champion du monde
voilà mais en effet de toute façon avec
la avec la couverture médiatique qu'il a
aujourd'hui avec ce type de champion
olympique avec ce qu'il dégage parce
qu'en plus il a un capital sympathie ce
garçon comme ces déséquilibres est là
aussi
et voilà et donc il n'y a pas trop
d'attentes justement raul aussi en ce
qui le concerne
en ce qui concerne tony hawk a beaucoup
trop beaucoup trop de beaucoup trop de
médias beaucoup trop de mots il faut le
servir finalement dans un combat contre
une tenue je suis en avance et aux
annonceurs du voltigeur haut niveau mais
mais pour l'instant il ya beaucoup trop
dangumeau d'engouement par rapport au
nombre de combats et à la classe de
boxer auxquels il a fait face à moi je
l'attends levée par la fin c'est à dire
la dlv resserre parce que aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la compagnie là il a enfin
voila il a pris 5 mai qui sortait du
champion de france quand même nom qui la
ville a battu un champion de france
quand même un ex champion de france mais
c'est d'ailleurs c'est le seul grand
boxeur qu'il est qu'il est battu et par
ex grand boxeur nationale par contre ce
que tu disais est très juste au niveau
de la défaite le fait d'avoir une
défaite pour eux alors le seul problème
c'est que malheureusement maintenant la
boxe et surtout un business en général
quand on perd très tôt dans sa carrière
ont déjà tout de suite on passe du rand
et ceux qui sont inintéressants et donc
la défaite effectivement je lui souhaite
pas non plus parce que voilà ça le rire
est de la carte définitivement comme
malheureusement parce que c'est aussi
vraiment vraiment un business alors pour
vous véronique il fallait y aller tout
de suite c'est ça la même chose mais il
faut ce combat entre anthony je choisis
les failles il ya la raison et ya le
coeur maintenant pour avoir suivi des
carrières de boxeurs comme souli sissoko
souli mba et hassan ndam etc
moi je pense toujours que tout est
possible et je continue à dire il ya la
raison parce que il ya le côté technique
etc
les vraies compétences mais aussi si le
gall annoncé qu'il a vraiment envie et
tout est possible et en deux ans une
chance de gagner
oui bah pas aujourd'hui mais quand même
à se préparer comme on en tue monte pas
sur le ring cité 10 qui vient pour
gagner bien sûr qu'il a des chances de
tony située contre ces deux
qui se battent donc bon voila mais tout
est possible dans l'histoire ça qui perd
veilleux 3 entre les deux mais bien sûr
que la maturité chez les poids lourds
elle arrive encore plus tard bien
d'accord un des détails zone ont
combattu très tard et très brillant de
13 à 19 ans oui mais il a combattu aussi
très très longtemps derrière c'est ça
que je sais ce que je veux dire c'est
que c'est du combat qui viennent à
nouveau de battre aussi helmand mais met
donc tony encore du temps mais voilà
tout ça ça doit se faire ça doit se
faire dans l'apprentissage et la monty
sages se fera simplement sic on revient
sur des adversaires des vrais des vrais
adversaires - le sujet on passe
maintenant notre rubrique débats dix
cyclistes dans cette page débats le tour
de france passera par les yvelines au
minimum jusqu'en 2023 les organisateurs
et le département signé une convention
en ce sens mercredi 20 mars
objectif préparer des jeux olympiques
2024 avec notamment un départ en 2023 du
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
on écoute le président du département
pierre bédier toutes les épreuves
cyclistes qu'elle soit à l'intérieur du
vélodrome ou à l'extérieur
ce le vtt le vélo sur route tout se
tient dans les yvelines
il était donc pour une logique de
préparer ce très grand moment
on reverra pas les olympiques en france
avant des décennies et donc
le département veut monter en puissance
alors pour les organisateurs ce
partenariat avec les yvelines marque une
continuité dans l'histoire du tour de
france on écoute les organisateurs le
tour de france dès sa première édition
en 1903 est passé sur le territoire des
yvelines c'était la sienne et moi à
l'époque
juste avant l'arrivée de la dernière
étape et c'est d'ailleurs le vainqueur
du tour de france du premier tour de
france maurice guérin qui avait gagné
cette étape là donc à un tas d'histoires
qui sont passés dans le département
d'une échappée formidable de bernard
hinault avec son rival all indéniable de
domec voilà jusqu'aux dernières éditions
pour cette première collaboration dans
ce partenariat rambouillet a été retenue
comme ville départ de la dernière étape
vers paris le dimanche 28 juillet une
première depuis 2012 après rambouillet
le peloton devrait passer par la vallée
de chevreuse joueurs josas muc avant de
quitter le département à vélizy à
villacoublay
la question sur ce thème est ce que ce
partenariat est logique
oui ou non oui leur lit vous êtes un
sauvetage
pourquoi vous est incertaine alors
toujours le coeur et la raison moi j'ai
travaillé quelques années sur le tour de
france cycliste le tour de france
cycliste et une grande fête familiale
toute la france libre sont du tour de
france même ceux qui disent non
si si ça permet traversée de découvrir
notre pays notre belle france et rien
pour ça c'est le grande fête populaire
je dis oui
après on sait que on est dans des sports
il ya d'argent en jeu et
il ya des coûts etc ça coûte trop cher
ça coûte cher ça coûte cher mais mais
c'est vrai que ya un an j'ai travaillé
sous ça coûterait cher vienne dujarrier
je suis super content c'est mon sport et
on l'amène à la maison formidable et en
plus le départ de la dernière étape
le jour où les gars sont là pour faire
la fête c'est à dire que vous pouvez
aller discuter avec eux ils sont tous
super détendu
moi j'ai eu la chance de me retrouver au
moment avant le départ fictif au milieu
du peloton avec maintenu normal j'étais
en civil a discuté avec sandy casar à
l'époque en plein et lui et voilà et
c'était la dernière étape tout le monde
est beaucoup plus détendu c'est le
bonheur donc super voilà les gamins qui
sont dans le coin pourront aller aller
voir les champions et pouvoir partager
avec eux le tour de france mais on parle
d'exploit c'est vrai que 3000 km en
trois semaines aux allures aux allures
l'été l'île les fonds et bien c'est loin
d'être c'est loin d'être facile c'est
pas donné à tout le monde
bien sûr que les gars sont sont préparés
pour pour le faire mais tous ne finisse
pas malgré le niveau de préparation il
ya des chutes il ya des ya des chutes il
ya des blessures il ya il ya plein
d'événements et des maladies il ya plein
de choses donc voilà faut être vraiment
un guerrier pour finir le tour de france
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est même
devenu banalisée aujourd'hui faire le
tour de france et voilà vous voit tous
les ans et on se rend pas compte
et pourtant ça reste un effort un effort
surhumain pierre chevallier décor le
décor et moi je pense qu'il ya il ya
plein de plein de raisons qui explique
sûrement le ce partenariat avec les
yvelines de raison qu'on ignore sûrement
globalement mais la première c'est on en
parle souvent ici dans sa démission
c'est c'est le formidable décor naturel
que les yvelines offre en vallée de
chevreuse notamment on est toujours dans
l'est dans les petites courses amateurs
comme dans les grandes courses dont dont
les départs sont pris dans le
département à parler justement de la
beauté et du quasiment du côté fait pour
des routes des yvelines pour pour ce
type de course je suis pas un grand fan
de cyclisme et je sais que le que les
yvelines les yvelines propose un décor
absolument unique et le fait de le fait
de l'institutionnaliser de le garder
jusqu'à parler de 1024 à moulin yves
épartement télévisuel c'est exactement
spectaculaire télévisuelle et c'est très
bien pour les yvelines - véronique en
parler oddero départ c'est cet événement
populaire
quel tour de france et qui a habitué les
yvelinois avoir ce type d'événement est
de voir la caravane passe et c'est très
bien qu'ici les cils et encore pour
quelques années
brown qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais
je partage exactement le même avis que
pierre c'est vrai que les yvelines c'est
propice au spectacle tant esthétiques
que sportif avec tous ces également ses
dénivelés et ses terrains qui sont qui
offrent de l'émotion sportivement
parlant
ils vont rester aux nouvelles et chaque
année c'est très riche comme comme comme
région mais on en parle
tu pourras me le dire iliad mais on a
parlé déjà d'une course qu'ils allaient
démarrer aux rivières
on en parlait déjà voilà des bréviaires
avait justement les bréviaires avec tout
plein d'endroits assez méconnu mais très
très charmant les haras nationaux entre
autres non plus on voit la soca gens
quand même je pense vent le vent a aidé
mais on a vu une très très belle étape
sur paris-nice départ de
saint-germain-en-laye vous voulez dire
pour la boucle dans les yvelines quand
même jusqu'à se voir décerner on a vu
une super une première étape où il y en
avait partout c'était c'était génial du
cyclisme à l'ancienne - de faim voilà
une au courage ouais enfin au courage
aller c'était quand c'est pas des gros
éditeurs les gros intervenants morts de
saint-jean-d'angély mais qui avait
amerri sang-froid 130 130 kilomètres
donc pour eux c'est enfin pour un
cycliste de la cycliste en tant qu à
tania kenny sanchez autant de kilomètres
si c'est pas grand chose en cours serait
même si je ne sais pas si ce nouvel
renouvellera chaque fois que quand le
quand le plaisir est intense on se
relâche jamais devoir et un plaisir
moi j'ai une course tu sais le village
le matin jeux là vraiment c'est
l'occasion parce que on voit les
cyclistes on voit les équipes derrière
etc
les mécanos on voit les partenaires donc
voilà c'est un rassemblement populaire
autour d'un sport et ça c'est chouette
je crois que ce que je vais apprécier
énormément ça va être le il va y avoir
un départ à versailles et
j'ai ça a été fait petit 5 6 ans je
dirais 2013 merci ce dernier c'était
devant château ces dix belles images
voilà c'était super sympa donc non tant
mieux et donc il y aura un départ
jusqu'à 2024 sur certaines - départ à
versailles 2024 ce sera le départ du du
vélodrome de saint quentin
c'est génial voilà il je pourrais pense
je pense que si je mets quelques villes
si je réfléchisse coach quelques villes
je devrais pas me tromper a vendu 2 aura
pas dans l'ordre mais je pense que je
connais de vie de départ qui partirait
de qui serviront de des parcours pour
les yvelines et il ya une histoire
également dans les yvelines christian
prudhomme le rappeler le premier tour de
france est passé par les yvelines pour
la dernière étape
sûrement sur les mêmes exactement pour
les mêmes raisons qui font que qu'il s'y
est installée et qui s'y installent
encore pour pour de nombreuses îles et
une logique on va dire l'historique
également complète complètement logique
et c'est une fois la proximité alors on
compte en parle de la dernière étape du
tour de france la proximité des chambres
de paris les gens disaient joue
évidemment beaucoup mais mais c'est ce
ce décor naturel et spectaculaire qui
fait qu'on a on a
exactement le décorum qu'il faut pour de
belles courses
l'accessibilité aussi des yvelines par
rapport aux feuilletons tour de france
les dernières étapes se joue dans le sud
et donc on arrive quand même assez
rapidement par par chez nous après ça
pourrait être ça pour être l'essonne
mais c'est vrai qu'ils n'ont pas le même
ils n'ont pas le même attrait est pas la
même même si le tour de france était
parti de langeron la première et à la
première édition mais ils ont pas le
même
la liste noire que les yvelines va voir
est au tour de france en effet s qui n'a
pas un petit un petit bémol peut-être à
mettre quand même que surface que ce
soit dans le même département
chaque année la dernière étape comme on
peut le voir les yvelines vers paris
véronique ce soit une étape comme disait
tout à l'heure il ya dujarrier une étape
pour l'honneur pour pour fêter ce tour
de france que ça ne soit pas et
finalement une étape une vraie titane
devrait étape
bah oui c'est alors il ya le dise l
avantage c'est que c'est décontracté
pour le public donc pour les yvelinois
ça va être
ils vont en profiter maintenant c'est
sûr que sur le plan purement sportif est
vraiment compétitif
ces jouets s'est joué mais la tradition
le dernier tour de france qui s'est
jouée sur la dernière étape
malheureusement en plus on s'en souvient
l'adolescent s'est réduit en phase avec
face à gries mode voilà ça s'est mal
finie donc il vaut mieux maintenant ça
n'empêche que la course et quand on est
sur les champs-elysées à ce n'est qu'ils
sont pas de cadeau à appeler finalement
en baisse où vous parlez des
champs-elysées il ya dujarrier on ne
parle pas des yvelines finalement on dit
de l'arrivée sur les champs-elysées oui
bien je suis amené ça nous fait ce que
on a on attend tout l'état parce que
aujourd'hui france tv couvre du départ
mais je me souviens quand j'étais jeune
on couvrait pas du départ de chaque
étape
pendant tout le mois de juillet on
arrivait quand les coureurs avaient déjà
fait 50 cent kilomètres parfois selon
les selon les étapes
aujourd'hui on couvre du départ du
premier kilomètre jusqu'à l'arrivée du
coup sûr sur la dernière étape un petit
coup de projecteur sur sur les yvelines
avec nos routes d'entraînement parce que
ben il faut pas oublier que la vallée de
chevreuse le dimanche 1
en quelques coups de klaxon mais c'est
quand même c'est dès qu'il fait beau à
partir du mois de mars 1 et même pendant
l'hiver vous avez même les tous les
jours toujours les acharnés mais c'est
vrai que le dimanche
et bizarrement on prend plus de coups de
klaxons quand on roule en semaine que le
dimanche dimanche on a l'impression que
les autobus salle que acsaq cette
fois-là actionner mais décide déroulent
soit là mais mais c'est vrai que ben
seynod d'entraînement on les connaît par
coeur et on apprécie de pouvoir voir les
cyclistes enfin les professionnels
enroulée sur nos sur nos routes de l'om
sur le plan international on en parle
les joueurs de france d'une bonne
visibilité pour les villes de mars
comment brouiller par exemple cette
année il n'y a pas faute sur la
visibilité c'est voilà c'est pipi c'est
mythique le tour de france et comme
roland garros et quelques événements
majeurs qui sont incontournables plus vu
c'est les jo et la coupe du monde
d'après sedo france ryder cup au numéro
3 mais nous on est tous les ans alors
que les autres c'est tous les quatre ans
voilà la question
il y à l'autre de france qui sera
organisé tous les ans dans les yvelines
mais également le paris nice saint qui
organise depuis dix ans dans les
yvelines
est ce que ça ne fait finalement pas
trop de cyclisme dans les yvelines est
ce que ça ne brûle pas un peu trop les
pistes non parce que je pense que c'est
ce que les idoles comme ça se fait
désintéressée de la course finalement en
en ayant trop de six fils j'ai pas j'ai
pas trop trop de cyclistes dans mon
entourage mais je trouve qu'en général
ce sont des gens assez mordu c'est un
sport qui cammas et national donc voilà
est jamais trop de vélos pour les
cyclistes non non je pense qu'au
contraire c'est un sport qui ne fait
jamais de rassasier voilà pierre vieu
d'accord oui je suis d'accord ça encore
une fois je suis pareil je suis pas le
plus beau la mater le plus je trouve que
cela m'a dit je suis d'accord avec raoul
jehl métro de sport même si tu vélo les
reliques jamais trop de vélo jamais
guaino jamais trop de sport sport
rassembleur au delà des différences
pense qu'en ce moment par les temps qui
courent vers heureusement que le pire
est là pour voilà c'est vraiment
c'est fédérateur c'est ce qui nous unit
tous l'amour le sport ouais elle a mordu
sur cette belle phrase de raul côte
réseau très heureux terminée par une
citation également de la tenniswoman
américaine ou tchèque martina
navratilova vous la connaissez je
suppose qui a remporté 18 tournois du
grand chelem celui qui est dit gagner ou
perdre
peu importe a déjà perdu je vous laisse
méditer sur cette phrase à bientôt sur
tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui